and every now and then you'll see these
cartel videos with these guys carrying
around these 50 cows and they show up
they stand there like yeah you know the
boasting about the rifles and everybody
laughed at them because
the 50 cal or anything like that without
an optic on it you know is like you're
gonna shoot you're praying shoot
basically see if you can hit anything
with it uh but now there's a a few of my
sources I've seen you know sophisticated
uh laser-guided uh rangefinders and and
sighting systems on some of these that
are being found out there how much
damage can 50 cal what's the application
they started getting them specifically
with the proliferation of armored
vehicles in Mexico Mexico has a giant
industry and armored vehicles as far as
so there's a race in terms of uh
armoring like protecting especially high
value targets
and then weapons that can deal with
those armored protected high value
targets there was a an attempted
assassination
of a state prosecutor somewhere in I
think central Mexico I forget exactly
where but she was uh riding around up
armored uh Jeep
uh Cherokee I think it was and their
main means of of uh Firepower was 50
cows and that car was left in pieces he
survived in it so I think the armor
vehicle company that sold her that
vehicle has it in the display room
uh then before my time probably two
three years before I was actually active
they tried to kill the head of public
Security in in the state of Baja and
with him it was a grenade launcher 40
millimeter grenade launcher it uh it
skipped off the the armored vehicle and
landed in the the car behind and made
the back explode uh one of the guys that
I used to work with was actually in that
car he survived it
um but you started to see oh they're you
know using our vehicles now let's get 50
caliber now to try and defeat that armor
uh
so that yeah there's there's there's
always this uh
this race of Technology basically down
there armored vehicles
you know how do you take on an armor
vehicle well there's a few ways 50 cows
you know if you can mount them in a
right way and shoot at a car like that
or a bunch of kids with balloons and uh
acrylic paint
on the front windshield and blind the
vehicle so it doesn't so they can't
drive it anymore there's another way a
tow line across a road painted like the
painted painted black so you can't see
it
and cut the thing in half again I'm not
saying any secrets these are things that
people have seen out there uh
shoot at the radiator you know uh some
of these radiators are not uh even the
more sophisticated uh Vehicles out there
don't have a sufficient uh armoring
around the radiator or the battery
housing or some of these vehicles
there was a case of a guy I think his
nickname was El pelalakas or something
like that I haven't seen Aloha level
cartel guy he had a normal vehicle he
was you know riding around and he got
ambushed he shot at his car he was like
ah I have armor you can't shoot me and
somebody went up to his car and just put
the barrel right in the locking
mechanism
and that got him you know so
it's an interesting place as far as
people getting certain types of guns
armor is prolific down there I mean
everybody down there look at cartel
levels you see them wearing plate armor
so that's an issue it's not like you can
shoot somebody Square in the chest and
go down are they afraid to kill
Americans
so I know I was traveling in Ukraine on
the front
so like a lot of the journalists were
traveling like armored vehicles
and at first I was like it seems like
this would attract attention yeah like
it seems like they would want to hit
those targets but then then I realized
over time as I learned
there's a there's a fear of killing
Americans there could be a drastic
escalation of yeah it's not worth it
conflict it's taking a beehive yeah
it's yeah there's there's there is a
tendency to shy away or stay away from
that you know I mean these they don't
want the Heat or the attention outside
of that everyone's game everyone's game
but also there's been many cases of
Americans being killed down there I mean
we saw the Mormon Massacre uh that
happened down there and all of them were
American Mexican they had both
nationalities and blonde kids you know
white being a massacred in the middle of
a desert uh and the car is uh basically
Catching Fire this happened and you know
America the Americans uh sent the FBI
down there to kind of review some of
what happened down there
and uh I think that was when Trump
started uh talking about kind of
Reviving this whole notion of cartels
being labeled as a terrorist
organization probably more for other
political
pressure point he was using to try and
get Mexico to reinforce its Southern
border which it hasn't but there's
escalation you know oh this this already
happened and nothing happened so we can
probably get away with it you know and
again there's a newer generation moving
forward now of people coming into power
more brutal more technically Savvy well
they have the experience of their
parents and the people behind them and
what they've done and one gotten away
with and now yeah more Savvy about
information Warfare their main
recruiting tool is tick tock
you go to Tech talk and you'll see a
bunch of these kids at a narco party
dancing around and some of these are
videos like cartel members filming other
cartel members in cartel control
territory and that's a window into that
life for
who's on Tech talk now kids
and the enticing aspect of that is the
money
the fun
the High Roller life and the possibility
of making it to a level you know yeah a
Fame of uh respect
power
money here in the US somebody might you
know I want a mansion like that that's
their mindset I want to live you know
like that rapper
down there I mean if you can buy a house
for your mom you know or pay off some
debts that you might have or a car
that's enough to kill for
so you also one of the many things you
did is uh you did security try to
protect in this in this war try to
protect people high value people yeah
how do you do you and others how is it
possible to protect a high value Target
like a celebrity or an important
politician in the situation so I was I
was tasked to protect uh the governor of
Baja and his family I was basically
replacing a whole contingency of people
that were already there that turned out
to be corrupted that wasn't my field I
was operational I was working with other
people doing the counter narcotic stuff
and uh the director of the institution
that I was in basically called me and
said hey uh
you're going to go and replace these
people and like what happened to them
well
I say you were known as a person that
could be kind of trusted I was tasked
for that so I I think they considered
that and uh and I I specifically worked
for uh
a governor named uh Jose Guadalupe who
was probably one of the best Governors
we have had in the state and people want
to see if I'm trustworthy or not they
can ask him directly and I I still speak
to some members of his family and we're
still you know friends in that way it's
protecting people like technically a
difficult problem to solve for my
experience in that time and in place he
was basically spearheading you know
counter the drug war in Baja when he was
in power so he had threats from all over
not only him but his family first thing
I realized working that job in Mexico is
that uh we had
we had people coming in to do
specialized training of that regard
Israelis you know teaching us how they
would do things in Israel that didn't
make a lot of sense for us in Mexico you
know uh we had people that had some
Secret Service experience kind of show
us how showing us how they would do like
celebrity the bodyguarding or
bodyguarding somebody maybe in
California of that nature
didn't make sense for us then we got to
experience some cross training with some
uh nsw Naval Naval special Warfare
people who were coming off uh protection
details in Afghanistan and Iraq is there
some useful crossover there we were
struggling with the acceptance that we
were basically doing protection details
in a war zone
so the approach uh that had to be taken
in Mexico with some of the approach she
would take in Afghanistan during a war
some of the overt militaristic type
approaches to security that we had to
adopt you know from uh
we didn't move him in a single armored
vehicle we had two of them that looked
exactly alike so when we would move
around we would switch one car to the
other every now and then we would arrive
to an event they would open the door and
it would be one of us and they were like
Hey where's the governor he's in the
back so he would move to that so we had
to do stuff like that
and again this is a young me who didn't
have any specialized training I was I
was on YouTube
learning learning some of these things
uh going online learning about armored
vehicles learning about architectural
armor I think you just described a large
percentage of the Ukrainian military how
they operate which is on YouTube trying
to figure out how to use some of this
techno and and uh that's actually
incredibly effective yeah you know I do
quite a lot of stuff where I'm totally
not an expert totally uneducated and so
on it's kind of surprising how quickly
you can get caught up as we're talking
offline if you take a course if you talk
to an expert if you learn from an expert
you can like catch up really quickly for
me it was all of a sudden I have this uh
director calling me in and I'm wearing
Vans you know in jeans you know t-shirt
and all of a sudden I had 80 80 some
people that I had to move around and I
was in charge of securing planes and uh
which I what do I know about that uh
airport hangers uh armored vehicle
maintenance and and purchasing and
figuring out how to set up a counter
assault uh group for for a protection
detail and I was like where I'm going to
learn all this
be able to quickly figure figure some of
these things out on the Fly basically
you know as I was going I remember
having this experience uh being in the
uh our security office on my laptop
figuring out how to set up a counter
surveillance uh side to our protection
detail basically how to have people
looking for people that might be looking
for us you know type thing
and then going to
uh San Diego to Coronado
and training with some people from uh
former seal guys and NCIS people who did
that job in war zones
and seeing them
critique some of the solutions that we
came up with on the Fly and being like
Oh we never saw that before Oh yeah this
is we're doing it down there so getting
that compliment
and also getting their you know feedback
like we probably do this or do that and
it's it was a learning process on the
flight that was pretty I mean seat of
your pants level is it possible for the
family and for the high value person to
um to have a sense of normalcy to have a
normal life I mean I tried I was already
starting off on the on the wrong foot
basically because trust had been
violated by the people that I was
replacing so I had to gain that back
than young kids in that family that
wanted to have a you know go out and
stuff like that in the most violent city
on the planet
so I had to do my homework and figure
out places where they were safe to go to
and make friends with certain club
Owners and figure out ways to put
Security in some of these places and
having to create this bubble of normalcy
around some of these people was pretty
difficult and uh there's no way that
that is a normal for anybody and
and oh God you know God bless them the
the I know it didn't I know it wasn't
easy and I know that it affected our
lives and they they lost on a big part
of their youth being under that that
security supervision and bubble
does probably does a lot uh for for
somebody specifically growing up like
that you know uh you lose opportunities
of
things that we take for granted you know
just going out just not telling anybody
and going to the store you know because
you want to get some snacks or something
like that that's not available to some
of these people
I have to be honest when I was in
Ukraine that was a really big benefit
you'd Escape no I couldn't hang out I
couldn't eat when I'm stressed I would
fast and not eat much so I get lost
weight which was great it's great for
the diet that's a good idea basically be
under protective custody that's a that's
a that's a good idea for a good yeah you
diet and just life it allowed me to
focus get a lot of reading done uh focus
on the important things in life
I mean uh a joke of course but there's
some
there's some complexity to this in terms
of normalcy of the family
but also just how to operate like have a
mental Clarity and a lack of fear just
basically be good at your job whatever
that job is if as a politician as a
leader uh even as a soldier somebody
that I like and I think this believes
that Ola said this to me or said
something like this to a group of us
that there's nothing wrong with being
paranoid it's about educating your
paranoia and knowing what to be afraid
of
if you're afraid of everything you know
you're basically overwhelmed but if you
start educating yourself as far as
specifically what to prioritize as far
as what to worry about
in a war zone uh working protecting
somebody you know you're not looking at
everybody's faces you're just looking at
their hands because that's what's going
to kill you you know that's an example
of focalizing you know what you're
paranoid and what you're afraid of so
looking at the hands that's the specific
to the particular situation but also
figuring out which situations to avoid
and which yeah it's okay I mean that's
like ultimately one of the biggest
things you could do route analysis you
know you you have to get to the airport
and you send off two cars to analyze two
routes and then on the Fly you just
change
trajectory to to create Randomness an
unpredictability and have that as a
security feature
um having to a convoy of four vehicles
separated into two convoys and show up
different in different parts to again
make it hard for people to guess where
you're going to be